et voici lagerfeld du destin des
germains la mode une france ils
balancent tout y passe et à des lakas
s'est plus senti portrait chinois du
germano suédois karl lagerfeld bonsoir
bonsoir
alors tu as dit en france on m'appelle
l'horrible allemand et en allemagne
celui qui est parti alors j'aimerais
avoir tout en doute quand même cette
semaine
tes réactions sur la victoire de la
droite en rda et adil depuis que j'en
avais dit que les allemands de l'est
avaient voté avec leurs ventres c'est
très facile quand on va tous les essais
libres de dire des choses pareilles je
vous ai pourtant quand même il avait pas
manger très très très bien depuis très
longtemps
il n'y a pas que le ventre parce que
leur système économique et et 15,02
jousse qui a parce que passer là pendant
40 ans et plus
c'était nul déjà du temps des nazis
l'industrie s'était pas tellement génial
dans cette partie le dernier parce que
c'était jamais il a vraiment la chose
industriel l'industrie cfai henri lévy
qui est polonais maintenant et l'autre
par exemple je connais beaucoup
d'industriels allemands à qui on propose
désigne alors ses usines dans la main
des lettres ne valent pas un clou
fédérer une vidéo et tout est à
reconstruire
malheureusement c'est encore l'argent
qui reconstruit ce n'est pas lady du
logis est ce que tu crois que les
français ont eu tort ou raison d'avoir
peur de la réunification de l'allemagne
non c'est au contraire pour un certain
temps je pense même pouvoir
économiquement affaiblir l'allemagne la
marque donc arrangé peut-être aussi des
affaires des autres
je pense que dans cette affaire tout le
monde se retrouvera tout le monde fera
des affaires tout le monde
trouvera un nouveau marché et puis vous
avez l'allemagne ça n'est plus
l'allemagne de la pologne l'allemagne et
et a fait prévenir ça devient nulle part
en europe c'est avec cette absurde une
ovation alors je n'ai pas avoir réussi à
sa famille est originaire de hambourg
veut monter à puisqu'il doit point
qu'ils ont traversés comme on ta famille
la deuxième guerre mondiale
je dois dire que j'ai de la chance parce
qu'ils mangent états unis en 1938 je
m'en souviens très bien de la guerre
c'est comme s'il n'avait pas eu lieu
parce que mon père avait eu la bonne
idée pour une autorité différents
d'acheter une propriété la frontière
danoise
juste avant la guerre et que j'ai passé
mon enfance les premiers donné ma vie
d'entreprise et à la frontière danoise
tout s'est rien passé mon départ on
était très riches tout en question oui
ça existe et quand même propriétaire
entre l'edf mais l'argent n'est pas tout
et vous avez le bonheur comme on dit ça
peut aider mais je pense que de faire
confiance à ses enfants et qu'on puisse
faire est ce qu'on a envie de faire
même si ça correspond vraiment aux
parodies des de tes parents celle des
plus grandes de ce monde l'aura 14 ans
qui est venu à paris pour pour faire les
études habiter à l'hôtel d'ailleurs non
vie d'un truc pour étudiants aussi
étaient très bien je trouve ça génial
c'est incroyable quelquefois je regarde
deux enfants étaient 14 15 ans et je me
dis comment je fais moi pauvre de tout
seul comme un truc alors à saison je
fais un concours organisé par le comité
international de la laine et tu as fait
un petit manteau en chèvre bio john
incroyablement passionnants
oui la préhistoire bref c'est l'histoire
de l'année la vente illégale
oui c'est une chose encore la gagner le
concours enfin ex-aequo avec saint
laurent vient d'ailleurs puis avait une
robe contre nous j'étais jaloux de
saint-laurent quand il était star 20 ans
avant tout appareil c'était le sentiment
que j'ignore et je n'ai fait rien par
rapport aux autres je ne fais des choses
que par rapport à moi il ya une styliste
anglaise qui je vais prendre autre que
j'aime beaucoup qui m'a dit un jour
n'est pas qu'au père n'ait pas compris
il avait vite dans la ville est ce que
tu es sensibles critiques quand on dit
par exemple
carlos est un excellent metteur en scène
mais c'est pas un novateur ou des choses
comme ça ça me touche ça les prairies
décrétant qu'il n'a jamais les critiques
et à petit
cinq personnes dans le monde dont le
critique une touche le rsa d'opinion
dans sa carrière a été assistant d'abord
chez balmain ou lycéens
c'est très bien ensuite été directeur
artistique chez patou une styliste chez
chloé et dernièrement bien sûr sauveur
de chanel tout le monde le sait sauf
leur sauveur sauveur
il faut pas non plus employer oui mais
enfin je veux dire ça a été aussi sauvé
si tout va sauter en danger lorsque le
proprio de chanel a mis les jedi à ce
qu'il fallait
parce qu on ne sauve pas uniquement en
prêt dans les lices en disant voilà on a
pris ce styliste et maintenant ça va
marcher tout seul donc quand tu dessines
combien de modèles par an à peu près
notre compte jamais ce que je fais pas
tu fais le plein de modèles disent on
est là au moins on parle de 1700 parents
quand même ce que sa plume et vous avez
vous confiance et aussi tout ce qui va à
la poubelle
ouais est-ce que je n'utilise pas et
puis entre méconnaissant allemand métro
l'écran italienne et tout le reste ça
doit faire beaucoup plus je ne compte
pas pour moi
dessiner essayez travailler dans ce
métier c'est devenu
une chose naturelle comme respirer ça
car il ya les parfums en plus et les
accessoires et tu as dit un jour cardin
maintenant c'est devenu un marchand de
soupe est ce que t'as pas peur à force
de faire plein de licences comme ça du
film on peut tabler à plein de licences
comme ça je n'ai pas envie d'avoir un
restaurant ce serait le temps puisque
les temps ni dans l'alimentaire dans
l'alimentaire j'ai pas envie de
retourner alors c'est un peu empêché
évidemment de connaître une une réussite
exceptionnelle tu es riche et célèbre
on va commencer par la richesse tu as
combien de maisons aujourd'hui
d'appartement bon je sais pas moi comme
je suis un décorateur frustant
réussissent pas combien tu dessines de
bonnel je vais bien croire mais les
maisons tout devient de se voir
l'analyse la turquie dans ce chantier
qui dynamita appartement à paris
il faut bien que le biais des mémoires
est d'habiter à nous tel serait pas
d'électricité que tout était là je
compose une pièce là bas pour une pièce
aux une pièce à rome tu as deux un grand
atelier d'un quartier où il y avait
beaucoup d'ateliers de peintre danois au
19e siècle et a appartenu à la été
l'atelier de doivent à un moment donné à
new york un petit lecteur
le message avait jamais je n'avais pas
beaucoup de bien à hambourg quelque
chose embauché maison sublime qu'il en
est d'ailleurs j'ai donné à la ville
d'avesnes ma vie elle est la vie parce
que c'est un monument historique très
très très bizarre qui n'est pas fait
pour ta grandchamp son manoir
l'angleterre vous et que j'ai hérité
mais j'y vais jamais l'année dernière
j'étais je crois 48 heures mais pour moi
c'est le pas nécessaire d'habiter de
l'endroit l'essentiel cela existe à ma
tête me dis que je peux en faire et
c'est un chantier très habitable g j'ai
tout l'arraché à l'intérieur et pas
encore eu le temps de refaire dont ceux
prescrits inhabitable je peux même pas y
toucher
paca une pièce avec ses 25 mètres de
long qui remplit de vivre c'est vrai
c'est bizarre
dudar à monaco tu as quoi alors tu as
beaucoup déposée par hasard plusieurs
choses de cette fameuse villa qui
resterait qui est in a occupé pendant
les visites et la vigie que tu connais
d'ailleurs
et puis j'ai aussi un appartement que
quand je vais avec moins de monde que je
vais tout seul à côté du palais qui est
dans une maison ancienne refaite c'est
cela qui fait 700 m² au 21ème étage ne
s'est pas suicidé l'échangé il est
moindre en suis fière mais il a plus de
charme parce que jamais mieux le puisque
le syndicaliste avait garé sur une tour
il était amusant il vient même fiche
mais c'était dans une maison nouvelle
évidemment jamais habité dans la maison
près de la maison sert qu'à mars et ça
mais ça dépend directement de la maison
de retraite avec l'ascenseur pour la bm
je vais plus jamais mais il faut que je
sois dans l'internât c'est bien trop
lourd pour tout perdu et 15 kg peut-être
un on peut pas monter en moi on la
retire mais pas les deux tu as dit
aucune des sociétés pour lesquelles je
travaille ne m'appartient c'est ça ton
système purement sur les usages des
royalties exactement pareil de
pourcentage vous connaissez les flèches
fille mais je ne veux jamais être
concerné par tout ce qui est gestion à
faire je veux garder un sentiment de
liberté totale et que tout ce que je
fais je le fais parce que je deviens
mais parcours obligé de le faire et pour
moi c'est très important
alors tu es riche depuis célèbre c'est à
dire que y'a des gens enfin il ya des
sondages qui ont été faits sur canton de
vaud avec son catogan son éventail tes
lunettes et par les parties non mais on
dit on sait pas très bien ce qu'il fait
mais on sait que c'est karl lagerfeld et
ça c'est une bonne chose mais c'est très
bien tu es arrivé à imposer une image
médiatique où il très fort à une chose
qui était moins médiatiques ont vraiment
parlé cinq minutes c'est la sphère inès
de la fressange radio
faire que la sienne enfin tu disais en
87 c'est un peu ma fille si j'ai signé
avec chanel c'est aussi parce que elle
est là c'est la française idéal de ces
problèmes cette malheureuse ce qu elle
n'a jamais pu s'imposer à l'étranger en
allemagne en amérique ils sont les
marchés importants personnel son impact
est ténue cela parce que tu disais c'est
la française idéal puis le jour elle été
choisie comme la française idéal c'est à
dire pour incarner marianne ce qui
effectivement là tu t'énerves et l
énoncé bourgeois s'était guère aisée ni
bourgeois ni vulgaire c'était au fait
oui pour dire gentiment à quelqu'un
puisqu'après madame atik j'étais jaloux
de l'état pour le dire c'était plus
entendu dire ça que didier n'en profite
je pense que de temps pour être
mannequin qui s'est passé parce que tu
dis qu'elle était bourgeoisement fins
appel quand même de la fressange et tu
ne te fais pas fun lagerfeld il n'y a
pas de titre en suède l'arrière
téléphone donc ton père était baron oui
ça c'est sûr en général c'est
héréditaire verte et kaiser quand même
mais ça je ne suis pas contre c'est pas
moi qui m'appelle comme ça c'est celle
fairchild donc je ne peux rien
tu penses que c'était mauvais pour
chanel qu'elle se finance dans sa salle
de bain
son petit goût la cave mais non elle est
complètement fonctionnel et n'était plus
une optionnelle maintenance et des
années 90 et c'est fini maintenant c'est
l'audi a6 faire c'est autre chose
claude fita n'aura jamais un contrat
comme elle a eu la sq nippo claudia
c'est bien ni personnel parce que je
pense que finalement les matchs faut pas
qu'ils attachent une fille cas que
treize années 80 mais non c'est quelque
chose maintenant le meilleur que je
n'aiderai plus jamais un mannequin de la
même façon comme les aider est ce parce
que l'ingratitude à ce degré a ses
limites et à travers toujours quoi je
vais d'andrea tu n'es pas bon tu la
connais je la connais alors par contre
est au mieux avec les monaco passé très
ami de la famille de monaco
ils sont mus élevé c'est vrai que tu
corresponds journellement avec le prince
rainier notre ce fossé trois jours il a
autre chose à faire
par contre quand on lis dans la presse
que tu trouves le prince albert très
spirituel ce que j'aimerais qu'on la
connaît il est très drôle ah bon donc ça
tu confirmes pas français très amusant
il a une grande nombre d'émulateurs et
acteur qui est assez méconnu mais on
trouve très très distrayant alors tu as
dit une phrase que je trouve très très
drôle dit dans le fond je m'en sors pas
mal parce qu'un bon âge pour être
pathétique parce que je peux vous vrai
je me pose tout un trop de questions à
votre sujet ouais tu veux qu'on joue un
jeu là ça dépend des jeux
[Musique]
c'était une gageure
colas très violent comme ça qui
éclaterait leur seul coup qui durerait
longtemps quand même
je ne sais pas vraiment rancunier mais
j'ai beaucoup de patience c'était une
maladie oh
contagieuse
[Musique]
les quatre est dit là ce qu'il fait très
mal de gros bourdon année c'est ça ce
serait qui pas dangereux
pourquoi parce que
je refais autrement pour fait tous les
deux 19 et que les femmes pendant ces
sur ma balle je les exploitent une façon
pinceau dit c'est clair si tu étais un
dictateur c'est d'un dictateur frédéric
ii de prusse peut-être que si c'était un
vice mais une discipine johnny gat et si
tu étais une guerre dans mon métier
évidemment une guerre en dentelles fait
ben oui un poison
je serai un poison je suis né pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou